en abril de 2020 un incendio se produjo
en la prisión número 15 de la colonia
penal de parks en rusia los presos se
amotinaron y acusan a los guardias de
maltratarlos muchos dicen que desde
entonces las cosas han empeorado
confesé que rompí dos cámaras durante el
motín de la prisión de angarsk
inmediatamente se lo dije al personal
ellos vieron todo nunca traté de
esconderlo pero por esas dos cámaras me
violaron y golpearon mi salud ha sido
severamente dañada todavía me recupero
si por boston doble huevo testimonios
como este revelan una brutal campaña de
represalia durante los meses siguientes
en la que los guardias formaron las
llamadas celdas de presión de los presos
para torturar a otros internos la ong q
largo punto net afirma que esto no sólo
viene sucediendo en hangar cge
y sitech y express cat actualmente
funciona una red de celdas de presión en
varias regiones los guardias
penitenciarios creen que es la forma más
eficaz de obtener confesiones de los
reclusos y controlar los problemas
pescan también esta semana el portal
publicó imágenes de presuntas
violaciones y torturas en otra prisión
de la región de sarátov y dijo que es
sólo el comienzo de una filtración
masiva de material que documenta el
abuso generalizado en las cárceles rusas
en respuesta el comité de investigación
de rusia que investiga los principales
delitos ha abierto una serie de
investigaciones al tiempo que el
servicio penitenciario federal ha
despedido a varios altos funcionarios
penitenciarios el grupo defensor de los
derechos humanos dice que esto no va lo
suficientemente lejos por lo que culpa
el servicio federal de seguridad de
rusia de orquestar lo que llama una
cinta transportadora de tortura